there are days if things are not going
right just put your head down and
continue doing what you're doing slowly
and steadily keep pushing it it will
happen I'm a very persistent person by
Nature so I don't give up easily well
obviously keep looking at the bigger
picture make sure you're heading in the
right direction My Philosophy always has
been when things are not going right
just put your head down and continue
doing what you're doing you will see a
better tomorrow in in a week's time or
in 15 days it doesn't take long to have
a better day it's just that some days
are good some days are bad welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctek
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much for being here I
really look forward to to talking with
you about your own company Journey
catharis Foods vegan lifestyle
plant-based foods and and what brought
you into this world and to create this
company and the products that you're
offering and and where this fits into a
plant-based movement in general and so
again thank you for for taking the time
to meet with me
um tell me a little bit about yourself
and and a little bit about your journey
into the vegan Arena
okay so I've done my uh graduation from
Mumbai India and then I went on to do my
Master's in business at Northeastern
University in Boston I had a scholarship
I'll post that I booked for of startup
back then in 99 which was an e-commerce
startup in San Francisco for a year and
then I came back to India because my
family was in India and ever since then
I've been with ttmg Consulting and after
that I was with captive and I quote
another 17 years so I basically had a
hard quote corporate lifestyle for uh
until I would say until 2017.
um I have well I've been seconded to uh
well to the US to the to to UK I worked
a lot for the European regions I was
very lucky I traveled a lot I met a lot
of people I've tried different Cuisines
and back then while I was you know
working for the European region and when
I was seconded to London
I was always uh you know I was always
buying organic baby organic yogurt
organic milk organic eggs uh because I
thought that the organic uh the organic
Dairy was not pumped with the hormones
well I was always very particular about
what I eat I work out every day uh even
now in my apartment while my lunch
discussions used to be around what did
you exercise today how much have you
eaten so out of Interest I used to read
a lot about what impact exercise and
food has on your body even when I had a
full-time job
so back then I was so well you know not
educated enough and I thought the
organic
Dairy items would not be would be
healthy and would not be pumped with you
know the hormone injections which make a
cow or produce more milk which in turn
you know you can make yogurt and
different daily items out of it uh
when I was back in India I was
accidentally introduced to a plant-based
Lifestyle by a fellow Jamon Soho and
plant-based lifestyle uh there is a
there is a company which introduces you
to a plant-based lifestyle it's a small
and Cat NGO kind of a non-profit
organization very close to my house
where I went and I spent time and they
taught us
um you know what happens to your body
when you have meat uh what happens to
your body when you have baby which I was
already aware and what other substitutes
how can you substitute your food how can
you even cook food without oil why do
you even need oil you can you can get
your body uh you know if you eat nuts
that's enough for oil and nutrition
going into your body good fats so uh
over a period of time Mom in my family
we transitioned to a a plant-based
lifestyle very slowly amid small changes
I've been trying hurry up with small
changes as to not changing my soil from
foreign
and I cannot even salt or Himalayan pink
salt uh you know trying to cook without
oil I even taught my cooked later how to
cook without oil so small changes every
day in our lifestyle uh we I come from a
community which is a heart called me
Peters uh my three to four meals are
they were all uh which all had eggs or
meat I used to eat a chicken leg piece
for lunch and dinner all my life ever
since I was a kid till about
2007. every day I would eat a chicken
leg piece without fail my colleagues
used to make fun of me because they
would see a chicken lick piece in
whatever I would eat
so I was a hardcore meat eater and over
a period of time Mom you know I started
transitioning slowly I knew again
chicken was again pumped with a lot of
stuff that he which goes into our body
um and uh it was very easy for me for
example to give up chicken we shifted to
a black tea and coffee that was also not
a problem there were times when I would
go out in the early days and you know if
I'm going to a nice fancy place I felt
like having a cappuccino or a you know a
latte uh and that in the early days I
would have oh the dairy milk but guess
what Michael over a period of time now
today if you give me or you know if you
give me a cappuccino or a latte with
milk I don't feel like having it I don't
like the taste anymore I prefer black
tea or coffee so it's also a question of
your taste but uh changing over a period
of time so anyway my family transitioned
over a period of one year or one year
two years and we've completely gone
plant place at home or my husband lost
around
20 or 20 kgs which is around 40 pounds
over a period of two years or with
exercise and wow very healthy um not
just diet so
um uh I more or less uh I became a
little leaner but I was I'm more or less
the same
um but the whole point is that we were
healthier so when covet started in 2000
um or in 2020
we continued exercising from home and we
continued our lifestyle uh
um you know I didn't even know I had
covet when I did get it I only came to
know that at covet because my mother was
around 82 years old when she felt sick
she was with us and that's when I knew
that I had covered I just thought I had
fever for a day so we didn't go through
any of the uh issues around covet
breathlessness or you know body hurting
or any of that uh during covert my
husband and I so it was very easy to
recover we recovered in like two days so
um it health-wise so tell me
so tell me a little bit about about what
you're what you're doing with cathars
food
of soap up just to add one Link's
modeling before I get there is uh when I
don't plan this I used to miss um the
cheese and my salads oh that's how the
whole journey started
um no I used to miss cheese and uh
whatever was available in India was
either well there were two three brands
which were imported and they were
terribly expensive
um plus they didn't taste anything great
and whatever little was available in
India was um uh when I was me was not
made with very healthy ingredients so
given my whole perspective towards
Health from the very beginning uh it
didn't make sense to again have
um you know plant-based cheese which was
not healthy which had lots of oil or
saturated fat and tons of starches
um so uh I that's when I started
dabbling with the you know making
plant-based cheese at home
um and I had a small vegan potluck uh
and people liked it that gave me some
encouragement and around
um three years back I did my first
farmers market uh in Mumbai where I just
took around tasting cheese blocks that
I've been I had made feta then that was
a flagship product made out of almonds
wrapped it in a simple pack of paper and
stood there in the summer heat in the
middle of May which is really hot in
India uh with my 10 cheese packets and
uh they were sold out which again gave
me some encouragement and that's how my
journey with kafaro started
incredible okay and so the the founding
story of of kathros and and how did you
bring those products first to Market
uh so
um I started slowly launching it in some
vegan stores in um in it moved by
because I'm based out of Homebase I
started with Mumbai I launched it on
some e-commerce sites e-commerce is
always easier than stores because there
are no returns Etc it gets easier to do
e-commerce uh physical movement is less
uh about uh after that uh you know in
the second year we went ahead and we
launched uh uh uh our uh pizza cheese
and a cheese spreads
um we won the best vegan cheese award
from Peta India for 2021 Anna cheese
spreads are available in six flavors
they are very versatile and I'm only
made with three ingredients uh fermented
cashews Himalayan pink salt and the
natural condiment so for example if it's
black pepper it's only fresh black
pepper if it's Cuban it's only fresh
cumin so again the whole idea was uh to
avoid oil to avoid preservatives to
avoid chemicals uh I don't think
pure in Greek
um hence the name katharos and we I
wanted to uh getting healthy plant-based
cheeses not just any plant-based cheeses
uh yeah
and six months back we launched the
world's first mozzarella and cheddar
blocks which are made from uh watermelon
seeds it's the first the reason why we
did that was
um we wanted to uh lower the price point
for the end consumer and also for the
restaurants and the hotels where we sell
so most people complain that plant-based
food is expensive
especially a lot of young people buy to
whose income levels are not that high
we're just starting their careers and
they find plant-based food very
expensive especially if it is made from
nuts
um hence we looked at watermelon seeds
uh there is one more option of course to
try uh you know soya but I kind of again
given my
mindset about eating anything I wanted
to avoid soya because soya typically is
a GMO product
I wanted to avoid it and hence we looked
at watermelon seeds
um it's been a huge hit uh it's a block
which great Sun melts really well on
pizzas nachos tacos so a lot of cafes
and restaurants uh by that of course
including a lot of retail customers so
that's been our uh one of our fastest
selling products but even our cheese
spreads and sauces because they are only
three ingredients they are super super
healthy
they're high in protein also
wow
okay so what was the reaction of of the
public to Pure products how did you how
did you get it out there in the first
place and and how did you start
validating the product that's you know
very consumer very consumer oriented how
did you what was the journey that you've
done with your product to really get
this you know tailored to the consumers
up it's really hard uh to explain people
in India what plan based or vegan food
is there is an awareness I'm not saying
there's no awareness especially a lot of
awareness in the Metros or people are
well traveled today or they understand
what is plant-based and weak but again a
very small segment of the society
understands that
um we do a lot of markets we do a lot of
events uh where we you know we put up a
stall of where there's a lot of tasting
to be done so basically I look for other
news where people can come and taste our
product and then buy it because then it
will get to taste it before picking it
up from a store shelf so then they
become a regular customers I mean
there's a lot of education required
amongst people who don't understand what
plant-based is a lot of people I'll be
honest with you when we are at events
and stalls the other word vegan and they
run away they don't want to even try it
so it it's harder okay it's hard it's
like sometimes it's like a negative
connotation weekend so I usually don't
always say Vegan I sometimes say it's uh
it's healthy cheese just dried it tastes
exactly like training and it's much
healthier it has high protein why
wouldn't you want to try it
um you know I tell them I bet it that
you like it because I'm so confident
that it's great we put out Samplers we
even make a pizza out of our mozzarella
and Shadow so people can you know try it
out up and all that has really helped
gain traction
um even selling it at different cafes
and restaurants helps because then
people ask oh what cheese was used in
this pizza and then the you know when
the staff says it's katharos you know
people go back and buy that um online or
in store so that's really again uh you
know helped us but events I think are
the best because people get taste it and
then buy it
yeah no no for sure for sure that's
really really cool and so tell me what
are the next few years look like for
guitarist Foods
uh B12 makes up four or daily limited
products
um you know and I know I'm very
confident that we can
um there is a heavy investment that we
need to make into technology because
everything is done sure you know this
that anything related to plan based is
basically technology okay so for example
uh casein is a product which is uh is is
basically something which is only
secreted by the cow and that's what
gives a mozzarella the stretch that you
typically see on pizzas currently that
stretch is not available in any part of
the world why because it's only made by
the cup but there are scientists across
the world exclusively working on
creating that plan based casein and once
we have that you know companies like us
will incorporate that into the cheese
and you know you'll get you'll get that
stretch that you look at in on a typical
dominoes or any um any
that you look at so now there's a lot of
Technology
involved in now making plant-based food
of tastier healthier better
um and um that that will continue
of your we are we are looking at
improving our products improving our
shelf life uh we are also looking at um
uh exports in fact next week uh and
traveling specialty uh for exports so I
have meetings lined up
um I personally believe that our plan
based of cheese spreads or what are
absolutely amazing
well for people abroad it's a very very
teen product and sign protein uh I doubt
it why would anybody not want to you
know buy it or try
um so we're also tapping um the market
abroad uh given the fact that the India
market is still growing is still small
it's not as big and matured as the UK or
the US market
very very cool and so you know at the
end just when the we we do this show
really to capture you know why people do
what they do so why
so if you have to look today at Terrace
food and what you're doing in the
day-to-day
help me distill why why is it that you
do what you do
oh I love doing what I'm doing uh every
day is different so for example right
now I'm focusing on exports I'm learning
every day up it's my it's so far stand
for me I've never done it before uh you
know the whole uh you know how do you go
about doing it or what other what what
is the paperwork required what are you
know how for example things like how
will that package it and send it abroad
uh do I have enough shelf life will it
last uh by the time it reaches there I
know the fasting behind it because my
first will change if I'm sending it so
every day something new and uh more
challenging at the same time we make
we're making such exciting new products
so we also have an R D team and that
parallel that's going on all the time
tasting new products testing seeing how
they taste how they you know uh how this
even people like it it's really exciting
um you know looking at say some branding
marketing of you know I felt being you
know being the CEO of a company I have
to look at all areas and um you know
especially two days back we were at an
event again and people loved that cheese
so it gives you all it gives you some
kind of a reassurance that people like
it and yeah we are heading you're
heading in the right direction
um yes there are days when it's very
frustrating and you know like you know I
don't know if I'll be able to do this uh
you know
there are days when things are not going
right but you know I just put my head
down and keep continuing I always
believe in that there are days if things
are not going right just put your head
down and continue doing what you're
doing slowly and steadily keep pushing
it it will happen I'm a very persistent
person by Nature so I don't give up
easily wow so just keep keep pursuing
things will work out obviously keep
looking at the bigger picture make sure
you're heading in the right direction
um I talk to a lot of um
my ex colleagues my friends who also
give me advice
um you know a lot of people from the
industry uh you need to meet to
understand if you're on the right track
but oh My Philosophy always has been
when things are not going right just put
your head down and continue doing what
you're doing you will see a better
tomorrow in a week's time or in 15 days
it doesn't take long will have a better
day it's just that some days are good
some days are bad
so it's it's been a great journey
fantastic thank you so much Jasmine for
coming here and for sharing with me your
story for these 20 short minutes this is
really great and I really appreciate the
time and the the energy so thank you
very very much and best of luck with
catheros Foods
thank you thank you Michael thanks for
ruining the time man doing this podcast
with thank you so much
[Music]